Woven from manila sisal or flax fibers traditional ropes are a binding element in our world
the process starts with racks of natural fiber yarns
The yarns are funneled through separators which configure them to twist evenly together
The fibers then travel through tubes that squeeze them into bundles
Workers tie the ends of the bundles onto a wheeled vehicle called the forming machine
They roll the machine back until there's no slack in the bundles
The machine is then sent to the opposite end of the factory over 1,000 feet away
as
The machine travels backwards its gears turn hooks twisting the yarns into a tight configuration
The formation of the twists ensure an even distribution of tension. This is what makes roads so strong
This long indoor space is called a rope walk there aren't many of them left in the world
When the machine reaches the back wall, it stops and workers cut both ends of the strands
They tie them to post to maintain tension and prevent unraveling
On one side they tie three of the strands to a machine that will transform them into a rope
Halfway down they bring in a cart that holds a piece of grooved wood known as a top
They tuck the twisted strands into the grooves of the top
They then roll the cart down to face the rope making machine a
Worker ties rope around the strands on the top
This holds them in place as the rope making machine twists the three strands into one
The Rope machine with twisting hooks remains in the same place
When the cart arrives at the opposite side of the building the rope is formed a
Worker removes the ties around the top they now have a piece of rope
That's over 700 feet long and almost 5 inches in diameter